Oh
residents of occupy la readied
themselves for a promise trade on their
campus midnight November 28 2011 today
is a special day because tonight at
midnight the the permit for to be here
and everyone thinks it might be a raid
of potential raid by the police right
now it sounds like people are just
radicals with solidarity as they
possibly can afford anything goes down
there
cool
we were told that the mayor made a
resolution have 14 days to veto it and
did not follow up on that we're packing
up because we don't just a bear we got
one buck an hour when time eventually
came for the raid of the grass and park
surrounding Los Angeles City Hall it
didn't come hello line came in with why
because we're in the streets that's why
I came if we were in the streets that
would have bought it with I'm first in
spring street right in front of City
Hall a lot in los angeles california
does riot police surrounding us instead
of waiting for the raid occupiers
advanced move to the streets so did the
Los Angeles Police Department setting up
police lines that create the closer to
the parks encampment we've been slowly
pushed about ten feet every half hour I
would say by the cops to the Sakura
location we moved about a block we have
a police line at least while you're
saying now we are about to be but
there's no
they're clashes in the movement also led
to heated exchanges early morning hours
they'll have to live here today's pissed
off it's no [ __ ] dad everybody here
tonight if you been here 40 days or one
day we are all pissed off in America in
the one but occupying these streets is
just as important Antonio Villaraigosa
tonight it's destroyed his political
nobody's going to want to ever hear from
him everything that we had aspirations
to become the president for state
senator it's over everybody performs
legally tonight to get out of street
they clear the streets again the
sidewalk it's not my intention for so
people should get out of the park yeah
yes I should have roughly you have a
partner the LAPD decided not to raid
occupy la that night but we're adamant
about clearing the streets for traffic I
hereby declare this to be an unlawful
assembly and in the name of the people
of the state of California command
although the simple to make a
intersection of burns of Main Street and
Wall Street in the immediate area you
shall immediately dis first Mississippi
occupy la was told they were going to
get evacuated for days ahead of time
they prepared for what happened and by
the morning they were still there the
next time they might not get a warning
it might just get raided for reason TV
I'm Paul Dietrich
you